thank you good evening everyone those of
you who are watching this your life last
week saw us do something we've never
done before we pulled a double surprise
at the end of the Johnny grant story
which you saw last week we surprised one
of the participants in his life
famous movie star and glamour girl Jayne
Mansfield you saw it just up to the
surprise where I said next week Jayne
Mansfield this is your life but we kept
one camera rolling so that you could see
tonight the surprise Jane's reaction the
reaction of Bob Hope Johnny grant and
all the others the bedlam of confusion
as the stagehands came in to ready the
stage for Jayne Mansfield's life which
we did a few minutes later before the
same studio audience now here's what
happened right here on this stage one
week ago what tonight this is your life
Jane Mansfield
tonight Johnny grants good night to you
Johnny thank you very much I don't mean
that we're putting you out well the body
is still warm
stop did you think it might be you oh no
not at all
when you bring in the scenery
take away the Johnny grant scenery
letdown for Jayne Mansfield scene ring
now Jane will you come with me to our
chair of Honor so recently occupied by
your very good Johnny grant to help her
over here I got it
we're in just a moment we'll unfold a
wonderful story of your meteoric rise to
stardom and now here they are your this
is your life host Ralph Edwards and his
glamorous guest Jayne Mansfield
hi thank you bye Maura oh how you feel I
I just really can't target we just shoot
pearl Johnny off here you know and
brought you on his was the marvelous
life and yours is really going to be
wonderful we have a lot to tell about
Jane Mansfield who in the space of seven
short years has leaped from total
obscurity to one of the most publicized
movie stars of the present day seldom
since the halcyon days of the silent
stream as there has been a motion
picture personality whose publicity has
so blanketed the world
I remember that Golden Age of Hollywood
Ralph and Jane Mansfield is a modern-day
image of that kind of glamour and Bala
who the voice of authority on Hollywood
past and present currently syndicated on
267 radio stations in the United States
Canada Mexico South America and
Australia
Jimmy fiddler in Hollywood
why do you compare Jayne Mansfield with
the glamor gals of yesteryear Jimmy not
glamour gals they were the glamorous
ladies of the silent screen Gloria
Swanson Carole Lombard Greta Garbo even
the sexy girls is Clara bull and Jean
Harlow
you know they lived in a world apart he
lived in the world of dazzle and razzle
dazzle and glitter he rode around
Hollywood and their rolls-royce
limousines and they had chauffeurs and
sometimes footmen in smart costumes
smart uniforms
well they dined and they played at the
old Garden of Allah they danced under
the stars in the Grand Ballroom of the
Hotel Hollywood believe me those were
the wonderful days that they have passed
on well they passed on that is until
they've been revived in the person of
Jane Mansfield and her way of them oh
thank you we have but to look at Jane to
see what you mean Jimmy by glamour as to
our way of life we'll watch that unfold
during the next half hour Thank You
Jimmy fiddler for painting the picture
of old Hollywood Alfred was indeed a
pleasure indeed a pleasure and Jane
continued good luck to you and I do
well there it is Jane there it is my own
the house you live in a cozy 20 room
cottage with 13 baths nestled on 5 acres
of ground surrounded by gardens swimming
pool waterfalls your own private shrine
why do you live like this game
oh we just we call it home we have quite
as the children in there and you feel -
I believe that maybe a movie star should
live this money do I think this debt I
think everyone should live like you
wants to live and no matter how small it
is or how big it is right your your life
is a waking dream where you live in a
make-believe world created for you
largely through your own efforts so
thank you let's go back and see how it
all began
yeah
April 19th 1933 the infant Barry Jane
Palmer first scenes light of day at the
respectable hour of 907 in the morning
at the Brynn More hospital Bryn Mawr
Pennsylvania
you know things I don't
I don't know why you were around I
wasn't it your baptized in the Methodist
Church the following June you're a happy
baby and when you first begin to talk
you name your favorite doll Maury
taurine ow what did that mean that was a
big rag doll I actually was wonderful
she was my dear friend I didn't have any
brothers and sisters and that was my my
fam Meritage did it come from Mary Mary
quite contrary or something like that we
couldn't quite get the source of that
but I don't know where it came from
let's just
well anyhow in 1936 your father a
prominent attorney dies leaving you an
only child and your mother who goes back
to her profession a schoolteacher in the
fall of that year Vera Jane and I had
the best times together rau yes you
recognize the voice of your mother of
course now mrs. Harry L peers of Dallas
Texas
yes with your father mr. Kator
I've got a Johnny grant got my
handkerchief and I when did Jane first
begin to dream of being a movie star
mrs. Peirce have you got a handkerchief
I've got my name is axel Bloomberg you
got one someone run one down here
because Bob Warren you have one thank
you very much no I didn't matter rather
this afternoon you've got one already
how do you like that
I'll keep this bottle mrs. pears but
when did you first begin to dream of
Jenny's being a movie star when did she
begin well
when Jamie was a little girl six or
seven years old Ralph her idol were
Shirley Temple and we used to sing on
the good ship lollipop yep I yield her
from every unpleasantness and built a
sort of pink lollipop world for her she
grew older she acquired pictures of
actresses and plastered her room with
him didn't she mr. Pierce
yes she used to sit in the middle of a
big bed and surrounded with pillows make
believe she was a movie star well you
you gave her singing and dancing lessons
and you yourself taught her dramatics I
believe his peers yes I did Ralph and
then as she grew older she had piano and
violin lessons and in fact South
Williams from SMU taught Janey and he
had hopes of seeing her in Carnegie Hall
she was that gift and sometimes she was
a little mischievous remember let's come
on over here and tell us about the time
that you entered the soap contest Jenny
well I could still get arrested you
don't mention the soap company I think
they'll forgive you I don't know I
always wanted triplets oh but it was
actually more than that of my own twins
or something and I read in Ladies Home
Journal magazine and they have always
won big pages of perfume with soap and
it said to each mobility bottom this
year I give a free cake of self and to
triplets are quintriple except it's got
a whole case I read it I was only nine
years old or something and I said I had
squint roofless Oh
one morning a singing postman came all
this over the world I haven't seen
behind the boxes and and Madrid are you
are you up his name I named the twit to
trip with it jammy Sami and Tamia
remember it's a good thing I'm not a
writer I would never be successful and
the first thing I know about it Ralph
was when all that soap arrived at our
house
well mr. material piers thank you for
coming here from Dallas to be with your
daughter tonight you'll see Danny a
little later
during your senior year in high school
Janie in January 1950 you marry a
marriage which is later dissolved you
graduate in June and the following
November one of the happiest events of
your life occurs right Jane oh yes I in
November the 8th I gave birth to a
beautiful little daughter Jane Marie yes
even though you're now a mother you
continue your education where it's the
University of Texas what you do with
Jane Marie during that time I went to
classes I put her in a baby buggy and to
go to classes with me and we we talked
about we talked to many people who
remember seeing you with little January
in the basket there you are acceptable
cutting up frogs with one hand I'm not
giving her a battle with the elbow where
else did you go to school what other
person you I went to Southern Methodist
University in Dallas and also UCLA of
maintaining a B average even earning a
grade of a in a philosophy course and
logic that's how that hardly sounds like
a girl who's been characterized as a
dumb blonde but to be an actress you
need that Matt Danny man spear was no
dumb blonde believe me Ralph the voice
of a man who knows you very well since
you were 8 years olds matter fact your
counselor at Southern Methodist
University where he's now heading no
psychological service dr. Harold captain
Jane was a fine student they doctor talk
and did she was rare Janey was in one of
my psychology classes that's in here
I certainly does we've been friends even
before that night like you said she was
serious minded hard-working students but
you know her ambition here says her
count on your book long burning ambition
of others to become a movie story she
visualized herself in this year's no
rapper dream has really come true Janie
you said it home for yourself honey
and you weren't after I'm proud of you
have a warm spot in your heart for dr.
Chau Southern Methodist University Jane
you'll be seeing dr. Chapman later the
pardon your honor at the Hollywood
Roosevelt Hotel where accommodation has
been provided for your fam - thank you
doctor
19:53 you and your two-year-old Jane
Marie set forth to conquer Hollywood you
work at our jobs you sell candy in a
movie theater they were posed for pinup
cheesecake photos through your own
efforts secured a screen test at
Paramount Studios but nothing happened
in January 1955 Howard Hughes stages a
spectacular premiere of his latest
picture in Silver Springs Florida two
planes from New York - from Hollywood
burying photographers reporters stars
and starlets fly too far debt and you
Jayne Mansfield a complete unknown are
there she created the biggest explosion
since the atom bomb your good friend who
covered that premiere veteran Hollywood
motion picture camera man and freelance
photographer Ted Fisher
said what happened down there well I
first saw Jane on the plane and she was
wearing the tightest fitting dress I
ever saw ha a woman yeah
as it turned out all the other camera
man was shooting still cameras but I was
lucky I was the only photographer there
that covered the event in motion
pictures well let's look at some of that
film and you tell us about it said oh by
the time we got to Florida everyone in
the plane knew Jane the next day the
girls were making entrances and bathing
suits there were some stars there but
when Jane made her entrance wound all
the photographers went to her like bees
to honey but in the next three days her
picture was in every paper in magazine
in this country South America and in
Europe thanks to Ted what color was your
bathing suit Jane it was red well I
maybe wasn't it read LeMay had two suits
I believe in the book man ah well one
was a bikini I think as you made your
second appearance and you remember the
suits Ted remember them how could anyone
ever forget I even borrowed this suit a
bathing suit look when they get back
from home bye guys
when I got thanks to Hollywood my
brother George Fisher on his Hollywood
TV program ran the film an interview and
immediately the phone calls came in from
Darryl zanuck 20th Century Fox pal
Wallace and Jack Warner and Warner
Brothers signs Thank You Ted Fisher
thank you within a matter of days the
unknown little girl from Texas is a big
celebrity complete with agent press
agent and Warner Brothers contract you
begin to live the adult version of your
pink lollipop world Jane Mansfield
so far no one has seen you act but
they're in for a big surprise there
Hollywood 1955 perhaps the most
photographed most publicized celebrity
of the day but you're still not a stars
you quickly learn when after three small
parts and pictures you ask for a release
from your contract your agent send you
to Philadelphia to make a picture and
then to New York to read for George
Axelrod and Julie Stein who are
producing the Broadway play will success
spoil Rock hunter what happens Jane I
got the part
yeah I think yeah didn't mr. Axelrod to
coach you how to read mr. Stein mr. oh
yes it was one he's George Axelrod told
me he said when you wake up tomorrow
morning that's when after we opened he
said you look in the mirror and you'll
see a star and I kept asking mister are
you sure I guess otherwise I didn't want
to wake up and he kept telling me and
telling me and telling me and he was a
very good friend of mine I'm Julie Stein
ears uh III Oh Julie he gave me my break
on October 13th 1955 the play opens the
Blasco theater and runs for 444
performances Jane was perfect in the
pottery tomorrow Ralph's a woman who
knew you more intimately than anyone
during the run of the play we knew you
would rather see her than just anyone
almost your wardrobe mistress Rose
colleague
typical of Genji want to be friends with
ever oh she's such a doofus well it
would refresh the Broadway appearance
Jane is that right soon as he's going ah
yes and Jane hasn't a nerve in herself
I remember the opening night when
everyone was so nervously pacing back
and forth Jane was sitting in the
dressing room pasting pictures in his
frat and it was her Terry to the aunt
Stacy she said cleanse I paste just one
more you didn't have stage fright Jan I
always had all my pets with me you said
a lot of animals Rosa she's a hard
worker Ralph and it was always
rehearsing her lines and was working
very hard but was never temperamental Oh
Polly for coming from New York to be
with Jane tonight
catching the plane one tonight for the
reviews you receive are excellent Jane
the press exploits your natural
endowments you become miss negligee miss
tomato miss lobster miss direct-mail
your Express agent Jim Byron estimates
that during the run of the play your
picture appears in newspapers magazines
more than 36,000 times you're the toast
of Broadway but you haven't reached your
goal Hollywood stardom
the publicity is working though 20th
Century Fox wants you the late buddy
Adler buys the play in order to bring
you to Hollywood where you begin a
seven-year contract at a four figure
salary a far cry from the unknown but
the determined little girl who came to
Hollywood only three years before you
immediately go into the picture the girl
can't help it with Tom Ewell and Edmund
O'Brien you're on target now and
traveling at a terrific tempo James he
always finds the time to be that are the
greatest mother
mr. Edwards avoid someone who should
know your ten-year-old daughter Jane
Marie
do you remember your first day in school
honey I sure do Megan had a reporter
this video that day but she was late
because she took me to my school first
she met my teacher and I got enrolled
yeah with your mother so busy are you
able to spend much time with her I yes I
do
um when she was in the UM in the picture
the little successful rock country she
called me every night and spelling my
lullaby the bed well hey you two have
always been inseparable so you should be
together so please sit here I know she's
your buddy Jenny she's going to be with
you there tonight and we're going to go
on with your story okay Jane Marie by
1956 you're on your way at least one
reviewer feels you're making progress as
an actress reviewing your latest picture
1957 the wayward bus Ruth Waterbury
writes in the los angeles examiner among
the bus passengers the most touching is
Jane Mansfield
as an actress she should be considered
something more than a phenomenon of
nature if ever she gets a role that
doesn't use her body first but lets her
ability and personality shine through
there will be some box-office records
smash but generally speaking the press
still sees you as a pin-up girl in
January of 1958 you take one of the most
important steps in your life Jane what
was that January 30 a wonderful husband
this 6 foot 2 inch 215 pound former mr.
universe Nicklaus Hargitay here's Mickey
Miki tell us about the wedding
well a wonderful guy he's been working
right through this here in Washington
and I know I'm married doing well I only
find may break that was planned to be a
simple wedding if the beautiful wave of
chapels in Basra is Portuguese Ben we
send out 100 in with a pink in with this
yes well pink is Jane's favorite color
it's Shirin and thousands of fans showed
up really and I saw November Jamie next
morning when I picked up an Uzbek
bracken believer we didn't know all
those people were there I didn't see any
we just ride around on a pink loud
sit right here beside Jane Jane you set
by Janie and to the right there
December 21st 1958 now December 21st
1958 that's an important day in your
life
oh thanks is my first time at st. John's
Hospital in Santa Monica and on August
1st of this year your second son Zoltan
Anthony is born at the same hospital
where the nurses tell us you are the
nicest star patient they've ever had in
fact there's a group of nurses from
Saint John's Hospital in the audience
here watching right now I see there they
are they told us you were no trouble
always time to consider it and you can
come back any time they said I'll be
back soon
hey Jimmy maybe we got a scoop I've
always found Jane completely natural
simple and sweet quite a contrast to the
pictures she presents to her public very
dear friend of yours Jane the associate
rector of All Saints Church in Beverly
Hills California doctor Kermit
kostelanetz better known to his
parishioners as Katey
well Casey my dear friend good to see
you
Casey and I are buddies and berryhill
dick yeah uh how well do you know Jane
Casey well I know it pretty well
and I know her daughter too
Jane Marie is a good friend of mine miss
Mansfield comes to church and Jane Marie
comes to church school and things in our
children's choir and his active in it
good many things there the mother
oversees that she gets there and she
can't bring herself why she sometimes
gets one of the neighbors to bring her
and quite often I've driven Jane Marie
home from church sounds as normal as
apple pie yes yes I've always found Jane
very normal and natural and human very
lovely it's wonderful to see her at home
too with her babies well perhaps that
can be arranged could we have the babies
please here we are
Nicholas Jeffrey he's a big boy two
years old a Mickey you old Nicholas
there we go because we have Zoltan is an
eight or month if grandma will
relinquish him will give Zoltan to
Mickey I guess or or give Mickey -
Mickey and Zoltan hold on - Mickey I
don't know but anyhow there you are you
hold him a family portrait that your
fans seldom see just don't throw it ah
you know mr. universe here he's so
strong he bounces him around mommy's got
her hands full they all want to go to
mommy here
well Jane Mansfield you've come a long
way from the pink lollipop world your
mother created for you where you could
dream of someday being a movie star your
two latest pictures haven't yet been
released it happened in Athens made in
Greece and the loves of Hercules in
which your husband Mickey here plays
Hercules many of the outstanding events
in your life are depicted on his gold
charm bracelet created and provided for
you by Marshall jewelers Bob Warren do
we have the charm bracelet thank you
Marshall jewelers Fifth Avenue New York
presents that to you and so that you can
relive this night we have a film of
tonight's program for you along with
this Bell & Howell sound motion picture
projector to show it on in the
16-millimeter electric eye movie camera
by the Bell & Howell company now in an
effort to combat juvenile delinquency
Mickey teaches classes in weightlifting
at the Eastside boys club and Ujjain
take an active part in all the
activities of the club so in the spirit
of the Christmas season the Mars candy
company is providing a selection of
thousands of wonderful Mars candy bars
and also in your name the fine folks at
Mars candy company wants the Eastside
boys club of america to have this check
for $1,500 we see an out Jayne Mansfield
with your baby in your arms surrounded
by your family and loved ones a devoted
wife and loving mother this side of
Jayne Mansfield is not exploited by the
press it's not exciting not good copy
but the glamorous celebrity is you've
created yourself in the image of the
most publicized Queens of the silver
screen these are the two sides of Jayne
Mansfield and this is your life good
night god bless